Whether you are hand-manipulating
and reforming stitches or knitting 1x1
ribbing with the ribber,
plan ahead for perfectly matched seams.
Having an uninterrupted seam is the goal.
As you're setting up your knitting,
each edge will be a bit different.
When knitting with a ribber,
make sure that one edge,
(let's say the left side) has two needles
on the ribber and the opposite side
of the knitted piece will
have one needle on the ribber.
This will form purl stitches on the edges
with a 1x1 needle
arrangement in between.
For your second piece,
place two needles on the right side
on the ribber and one needle on the
opposite or the left side on the ribber.
This is what the two pieces would look
like next to each other, as if you were
looking at them from the private side.
You'll see two purl stitches on one
edge and one purl stitch on the other.
When seaming, use a full stitch mattress
stitch and the 1x1 sequence is
uninterrupted.
Now when you're hand-manipulating the same
holds true if you're reforming
for 1x1 ribbing.
Always remember you don't want to reform
those edge stitches so they remain purl
stitches as viewed from the private side
that's facing you on the knitting machine.
The trick is to leave two stitches plain
on one side of the knitting
and when the edges are joined,
you'll get the desired results.
Maybe a bit of a brain twister at first.
Right side, wrong side,
private and public sides.
But the bottom line is you want to end up
with two purl stitches on one edge
of a piece and one purl stitch
on the other edge that's going to join.
Take time to plan this ahead
for beautiful 1x1 ribbed seams.